un intento de
desesperante es el encuentro cara a cara
de 30 minutos entre manuel macaco y
boris johnson al margen del g20 y
pretendía resolver la crisis de las
licencias de pesca al final de la
reunión en el elíseo anunció que los
dirigentes habían acordado que se
adopten cuanto antes medidas prácticas y
operativas para evitar un aumento de la
atención pero por el lado británico
siguen mostrándose resistentes a las
represalias anunciadas por el país el
cierre de los puertos franceses a los
pescadores británicos y el aumento de
controles aduaneros están previstos a
partir del martes buscan animar a
londres a respetar los acuerdos de pesca
post exit el número de licencias
asignadas a los barcos franceses para
entrar en aguas británicas está muy por
debajo de lo que establecen los acuerdos
si el gobierno francés quiere presentar
propuestas de desescalada en la relación
con respecto a las amenazas que se
hicieron serán bienvenidas nuestra
posición no ha cambiado el viernes la
embajadora francesa en londres había
sido convocada al día siguiente boris
johnson mencionó la activación del
artículo 16 del acuerdo del proxy que
establece el procedimiento de resolución
de conflicto y se quejó ante la
presidenta de la comisión por la actitud
de francia
tengo que decir que me preocupa un poco
que francia esté a punto de incumplir o
haya incumplido ya el acuerdo de
cooperación comercial que habíamos
acordado
pero la pugna continúa a pesar de la
reunión en roma el martes sería el
último plazo para llegar a un acuerdo
sobre las licencias de pesca antes de la
imposición de represalias por parte de
francia